boltonaro supporters are always said  that the polls were wrong they're not  necessarily wrong it's just that some of  the votes for other candidates have  actually gone to a bolsonaro robin  Tallulah  I think one of the concerns for many  people though is as in this Gap we now  have between the rounds is where the  Electoral violence could increase we  know there has been some already and it  could be pretty volatile there's a sort  of real sense of how this country is  really divided I mean virtually in half  Luna supporters are convinced that they  will win in the second round and they  deny that bolsonaro's team will feel  that they've got some momentum with them  the polling had shown that bolsonaro is  nowhere near getting through and of  course he actually is very close indeed  everything sort of fightful still for  both sides  disappointment here but I suppose  this Beluga supporters  have another go at it and they're  convinced they will win in that second  round